a lot of us may think that america needs
to have a little ice cream and chill
yeah because we've been angry lately
have you noticed and that's where we're
going to begin this hour it's a question
facing our country
do we have an anger problem you have no
doubt seen these videos gail says yes
people venting frustration or in some
cases full-blown rage just about
everywhere you look much of it covert
related but not all of it
nearly three-quarters of americans are
at least somewhat angry according to one
recent poll another poll shows that 84
of us believe that we are angrier today
than we were a generation ago but think
about this considering the state of the
country is that too much anger or not
enough
and who you calling angry anyway that
too turns out to be a matter of argument
let's just start at the beginning on a
recent day in new york we met up with a
man you may not realize you've seen
before you're a bunch of cowards hiding
behind our children brandon michonne is
the man in the gray hoodie in this viral
video from a school board meeting back
in january the garbage workers who pick
up my freaking trash
risk their lives every day
more than anyone in this school system
he had moved his family from new york to
northern virginia last year and grew
frustrated by delays and plans to reopen
the schools figure it out
or get off the podium his entire speech
was only about a minute long but intense
it's not a high bar
raise the freaking bar and it didn't
stop after michonne walked off camera
can i ask the deputy to please make sure
the gentleman had leaves the board room
have you watched yourself back have you
seen the video lately i've heard it a
lot you've heard it can i show you the
video do you mind as we watched him
watching himself though figure it out
get off the podium it became clear he's
in fact proud of his performance i
thought it was a heartfelt
speech of you know frustration passion
do you have any regrets nope
no what i said
the words i said there was nothing wrong
with what i said at a time when more of
us seem to be saying and doing things
out of anger researchers are also
learning more than ever about where that
emotion comes from what exactly is this
guy's problem we got a crash course in
anger at ohio state university's driving
simulation laboratory where professor
brad bushman is researching what leads
to road rage why are you investigating
this
i'd like the world to be a more peaceful
place and i think science is the best
answer to
what risk factors predispose people to
behave aggressively he's found having a
gun in the car can somehow prime people
for hostility this is called a weapons
effect there's a very strong connection
in our brains between guns and
aggression and so just the mere presence
of a gun can make people more aggressive
but bushman says there may be an even
more basic risk factor empathy levels
are going down narcissism levels are
going up and that's a big problem for
society anger has a lot of stigma
towards it new york university
psychologist dr ariane ling says anger
is natural and her professional response
to the people who've been photographed
or recorded in those moments
is not outrage but sympathy that person
in that video is really suffering in
some ways so
i i see that the anger is an outward
expression of i'm so fed up or i'm so
scared or i'm so whatever the other
emotion is i can imagine that if they
could or wanted to respond in a
healthier way
that they would hey how are you of
course americans have always had a long
list of not always important things that
make them angry i don't like it when
people stand up on the airplane probably
traffic in the city not getting a text
back in a timely fashion this drives me
nuts i can't the the sirens but dr ling
maintains as long as it doesn't tip us
into violence our capacity for anger is
actually positive there's good reason
why evolutionarily speaking we can still
experience anger anger has been
motivating and powerful and has also
kept us alive
it motivated you to maybe respond
aggressively to fight to do something
about the threat that you're
experiencing so anger appropriately
channeled can be a force for good
absolutely
absolutely and that's exactly how
brandon michonne feels about what he
calls his moment of passion there's a
time and a place for certain passions i
think this one
albeit some people i may have a
differing opinion was justified and the
impact i think started a conversation
around the the world you acknowledge
frustration
why not just call it anger because
there's two different things
anger
anger is
you know anger can be violent
passion
can be justified
so i see this different brandon michonne
i actually understand where he's coming
from now when you just play that tape
where he where he appears on a big rant
then you think oh but when you hear the
back story and you see his explanation i
actually get that yeah and you
understand his his kids talked just
before him and he just sort of lost it
watching them and in his view being
ignored
and their education suffering but this
this changed my view of anger because i
thought anger was kind of the dumbest
emotion something to suppress something
to avoid and for a long time
psychologists thought that way too but
it's kind of been redeemed in my eyes
and also in the field people now see it
as natural and productive one
psychologist who we didn't speak to but
who had something interesting to say on
it said anger alerts you to injustice
and prepares your body to fight that
injustice yeah but the anger we see on
planes though
i'm not okay with that i think that
that's there are different kinds of i'm
now learning there are different kinds
of anger so when you see those people
just going nuts on the plane i don't
care what is
what has happened that's just
inexcusable to me and that's just not
okay tony you made a good point when
talking about channeling that anger
tapping into it properly you look at
some of your favorite artists or even
your favorite athletes there is a place
of rage that they go to before they take
the court or the field or even the
boxing ring i just feel like in moments
where you know confrontation is
inevitable you have to figure out a way
to communicate it the best way yeah
because having a public meltdown it
might be a good way to get your point
across because you're going to get
attention but who's on the other side of
that receiving it because oftentimes
when you're getting screamed at by
somebody you close up or you fight back
you can't even hear it when you're
getting screamed like that you can't
even hear it i mean and sometimes
sometimes
angry people aren't some people just
jerks the guy throwing the machete or
the guy yeah yeah yeah that's just not
okay yeah i mean you think it's very
interesting
you can make progress progress can be
driven from a place of anger think about
john lewis good trouble get into good
trouble
but at the same time you can be very
wrong about something and if you're that
kind of angry about something you're
very wrong about then you're a jerk i do
like your pieces though as nate said you
just roll up on people start talking
because you never know how people are
going to react that was really really
good people are always games well done
tony thank you very well done